welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid a few months ago I posted a video
on entropy and I got a lot of comments
asking for more okay that's a lot of
comments the explanations in that video
work fine as long as all you're trying
to do is regurgitate some words onto
some tests but if you think about them
at all they might leave you wondering
learnt order and disorder kind of
subjective and personal how is it
possible that the universe loses
information over time if it never really
had the information to begin with why
does entropy even matter whoa whoa hold
your horses that last question is a
little more difficult to answer so let's
address the others first entropy isn't
really about order and disorder in the
way you usually use these words
I'm sure the Internet has some
definitions okay that's some serious
ambiguity English really sucks sometimes
so let's just avoid these words
altogether we've run into similar
problems when we try to use the word
information so let's just avoid that one
- ow
hmm what does that leave us with
statistics
I hate statistics as much as the next
person but I think we can manage this
let's get our heads in the right place
using pennies
since demonstrations are all they're
really good for anyway I have a bunch of
pennies here from the teddy bank all
from the same year and all equally is
dirty each penny has two possible states
it can be in heads or tails right now
the single penny reads tails but if I do
this it could be in either can't we just
check and see what it is yes yes but
that's not the point the point is on any
given shake it only has a 50% chance of
recovering that original state okay
that's kind of boring let's make it more
interesting
this set of pennies is in the state
tails tails give it a shake though and
it now has 2 times 2 or 4 possible
states since we can't tell the pennies
apart tails heads and heads tails are
indistinguishable it is twice as likely
to be in one of those states than it is
the original tails tails bigger
three pennies has 2 times 2 times 2 or 8
possible States the mixed States are
becoming progressively more likely
bigger for pennies has 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 or 16 possible states bigger oh
yeah
50 pennies has 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
to the 50th power or a little over 1
times 10 to the 15 possible states
that's over a thousand million million
well that escalated quickly most of
those states are relatively even
mixtures of heads or tails because those
are far more common and that's only 50
objects each having two possible States
a real collection of particles would
likely have millions of millions of
millions of millions of particles each
with a very large number of possible
states don't even try to picture that
because no one can just got real the
entropy of any collection of particles
depends solely on how many energy states
are accessible in other words how many
ways that energy can be tucked into all
the spots so why does it matter because
it always goes up the second law of
thermodynamics says the entropy of any
closed system tends toward a maximum the
only truly closed system is the universe
but we can get pretty close in the right
lab environment so how do we really know
it always goes up that's actually a
question I asked myself recently so I
did a little research and I discovered
something mind-blowing we don't actually
know for sure in fact there's nothing in
any other physical law to even suggest
it the second law is simply necessary to
explain all the observations we make
assuming it's true though it does tell
us a few things heat must always flow
from warmer to colder areas never from
colder to warmer 100% energy efficiency
is impossible there is always a loss to
the environment seriously though what's
that mean oh yeah I guess relevance
would be a good idea without the second
law of thermodynamics we could never
completely explain super heating or
super cooling we'd never know how well
we could build an engine an oven or a
refrigerator and we'd have no way of
predicting the ultimate fate of the
earth the Sun or the entire universe it
lets us know our limitations which is
something we should always be aware of
so what have you done to increase the
entropy of the universe lately I'm
gearing up to run my air
non-stop for three months because merica
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy oh oh I almost
forgot some of you may have already
noticed but I started a vlog channel so
click anywhere right here go check it
out